and no way to welcome to this video Robo
little is my opponent and thought plata
before words the statistics clearly
state otherwise and i'm not going to
question the statistics in okay we place
the main line here logistics first right
castles is normal
not canceling they don't have to i mean
you can probably probably also play like
a for maybe one point is that 95 fails
to ya this is the main move actually so
a 4 is it a threat now no not yet yeah i
mean you can play a forward he's not
going to get to be five more that easily
ok so here there are a couple of options
Quincy for as one of them look before
it's also a move I think if I remember
this correctly so I go Quincy phone I'm
not quite sure this is right
there's one of the critical idea of the
bangko gambit parula which as the
slightest called ya know Roble dito is
taking some time this is mostly to
prevent 95 h3 is a decent movie 'um to
make nigerian possible monitor one of
the options that black hairs queen bee
three ll s also thumbs something i
wonder look III is also making sense all
that that looks sophisticated so night
night to detune i'm not going to
reinvent the william
one thing you always have to keep in
mind this is not easy for y to play it's
got those things slightly awkwardly
position pieces and dumb it's not easy
so here can I regain the pawn let's
check this first probably not Bishop c3
I mean that that doesn't work it's rugby
30 move radius not show him I can also
play pawn to c4 but then probably night
a tune
not quite sure but I don't want to spend
more time on this
maybe rupee 3m right it's not it's not
very natural looking maybe Queen before
actually on that move could dunk that's
an idea 24 it looks extremely weird
Queen doesn't have a hiss squares but
it's got d3 which is important check
okay so slide the five the point maybe
but it's that bad huh maybe you can take
played III I've Bishop h6 though this is
going to be an awkward more awkward move
to face or not how is he actually
answering this you cannot move the night
cannot move the bishop so that wind
stuff yeah it's it's always active
advanced material
yeah that means I don't know what
exactly they exchange maybe I don't know
maybe cannot actually save that save a
pc hmm maybe maybe ff4 mm-hmm it looks
looks pretty terrible that you probably
have to do it well that works it works
like clockwork now it takes d5 we should
be three check check quite resigned no
this is not easy for what to play this
opening is not easy to play then let's
get there none of this on yeah here oh
this is this is a theoretical position
and I'm not quite sure there's Queen c4
and look before I think I recommended
before but Quincy for is also not
terrible I didn't quite remember
everything correctly look before I think
what I recommended in my repertoire but
this isn't bad either bishop's you wanna
if you have to play that move okay let
you form 92 I'm very active it's not
easy at all stop purchases on equal here
this is this could be a tricky decision
and I gt5 not sure he went here and now
queen d 4 is funny maybe there's some
drawback to this but I didn't quite see
it
computer also doesn't find anything
special so this yeah so here night c4 I
had to be played instead of B 3 B 3
wasn't was blundering her be sure wow
he's got Bishop a 3 wow that's a hidden
resource I didn't see her at all ok
night c4 is given by by the engine
ultimately so what do I do here I hate
it says equal but i don't i'm not quite
sure how it is equal ok 8 b 3 and then
the night up ok like takes a daisy form
yeah and that might lead to complete
elimination of everything ok tough tough
tough to play and we both didn't see
Bishop a 3 that's funky and ikea look do
you wanna amazing engine gives equal
tough to say it but that wouldn't be
obvious to me that this is equal I'm not
saying I better I'm just not quite sure
what it is ok so yeah I'm winning quite
straightforward lamb yeah i was a bit i
was helpful him that he didn't see be
three Bishop e3 but that these kind of
things are difficult to see ok guys
thanks for watching